but the real problem when we hear all of
this stuff and I want you once you guys
start hearing this you cannot hear it
when you start hearing women say he
didn't meet my emotional needs he spent
too much time at work that is the
indication or my favorite one I did so
much for him that is the indication of a
woman that one keeps score that will
resent you if she has to give up
anything
and a girl that competes with her
husband and a woman that is controlling
there is nothing worse than a
controlling woman why because as women
it's like we don't even know what we
want one day we want this one day we
want that one day we feel this one day
we feel that it's like we are not meant
to be in control
yet